let me get to Sean Solsbury friend of
the show former college pro quarterback
and now a Sports Talk host on 790
Houston and Sean joins us now good
morning Sean how are you I'm doing great
and I love this plan by the way thanks
for having me off well I don't know if
we get to the point where we just say
this is about big business and let's
let's pull the curtain back and let's
organize this so do you think that
there's ever there's gonna be this type
of setup in the next you know near
future next 10 years I do and Dan I
don't know why we wouldn't and as
reading over I think Polly put this plan
together and you guys are talking about
it well there's money to be made
there's fan obviously interests you get
people that you know for instance if
it's Alabama or Clemson or somebody else
who represents and gets to play a home
game then people there go it'll be we
won't have empty facilities I just think
if there's pressure there's clear there
is more opportunity now we don't have
the argument over conference champions
should they be automatically in you get
the wild cards to the little guy they
still have a chance to you know it was a
bit hung around for just missed out hell
yeah I do
then we need some change we definitely
needs to change because right now if I
ask you looking at schedules and off and
I like the eight games and then you know
the nine games and then the three
non-conference where you're playing in
your own conference think about this
what is Alabama and let's say fall
flight now LSU may get them but Clemson
with their schedule Dan don't they waltz
to be to the finals I mean aren't they
in the Final Four no matter I mean they
could play with yeah doesn't it I mean
even though they're not playing great
football they're gonna walk so looking
over this and I just got it a few
minutes ago and I actually like it I
need something that gives me more
intrigue home games I like that and then
I like the FCS talk to Paulie and you
should post that on on Twitter and on
social media I think it's a really
really good idea and I think we need
some some reform going on in college
football to add the next level of
interest I do and a chance if I let
these teams these schools and you play
at these schools and I give you minimum
wage for the hours that you put in and
you
control your likeness I'm gonna guess
these players plan in you know the big
five conferences that we'll have
probably will sign off on this yeah oh
there's no question about it when people
say well the rich get richer well
there's only so many scholarships to go
around damn right so you can't have 115
guys like the old days when the top six
running backs would go to USC they're
gonna have to spread the worth to I am
I'm all for it I'm 100% pork and I get
them back just a part of the likeness
I've never understood for instance we
assume that everybody's gonna go earn
money on a Sunday know the peyton
manning's and Tom Brady's aren't the
norm that's the aberration the guy who's
in the league two years and leaves is
that so he may not make a lot of money
in the NFL him why shouldn't I what if a
guy Dan I'll use me as an example if you
don't mind coming out of school number
one recruit went to USC sure you know
Mel Kuiper's List gonna be a first-round
pick I shredded my knee twice now
growing up in California and being in
Los Angeles
how many speaking engagements while I
was the Trojans starter could I have
gone and made money on and then I went
on and was a non drafted free agent made
a t25 as a rookie not paid million five
hundred thousand it would have been nice
been nice to start out and say man I'm
just using me as an example I get it and
when they say well the backup
quarterback is not going to get as much
and the vice president it doesn't make
as much as the president when it comes
to a corporation or a company so I am
foreign and there's ways to work around
it I don't like hand to hand cash from
the University at least now unless we
all had a hand in it but I the likeness
I don't see why Trevor Lawrence
shouldn't be able to make money on a
shoe deal Dabo Sweeney does and when
somebody tells me well Sean it's free
education free free education yeah
summer vacation most of the guys I know
were busting their butt trying to get a
scholarship and going to class and
playing summer league baseball and it
gets going vacation I know in my house I
couldn't because my dad said when you
commit to a team or practice you're
going to stay there and practice for a
team we're not going on summer vacation
so I don't know when anybody says that
it was a free education because you got
to earn it so I have a strong strong
feeling about that when people say oh
you got a free scholarship no I actually
didn't either and every
did you know you know what to name any
names did you get offered cash offers or
a lot of it cash cars real a ttle saddle
cash I had one one-on-one head coach
call me and say you come to our school
you'll never have to worry about wheels
the rest of your life I so the cattle
probably wasn't a California school in
Texas or Oklahoma no names
what's the biggest cash offer you got
out of high school well I probably say
that it was more than six figures more
than six figures yeah and damn again
this was no secret we got the trouble
for this we were put on probation at SC
this is not something I'm just pretty I
can remember when I was at the Trojans
and we had an alumni and member loumac
ad when that ticket scalping we were put
on probation for a year were you five
tickets me tell him from what you know
that's that valuation yeah well you had
an alumni and I can remember when I had
mine did walk into here to talk and I
could remember at the time and we'd like
I said this isn't some oh my gosh we
were put on probation for ticket
scalping then that came in the point
where you had to show a pass at the gate
with ID for family then I walked in my
alumni memory we walked into the
bathroom I was handed an envelope
we're like when we played Notre Dame
UCLA because we got extra money for that
so I'd sell my eight for eight tickets
we had to an alumni I'd be handed cash
in my little little brown envelope and I
would take it home with me and that was
my pizza money for the second semester
how much was it and I probably I think
the most I got eight Notre Dame tickets
at home was probably just under 3 grand
3 grand son like that well Shawn hold on
Paulie we have the IRS on the phone and
the NCAA and the NCAA they'd like to
talk to Shawn well I got this for you
tell them I already get my rock bottom
[Laughter]
another cop after probation and when you
went to the NFL locker and the guy from
the school sitting next year it was
booked and I'm not saying everybody was
doing it you just thought it was the
norm and then when you get put on
probation you no longer had a
hand-to-hand ticket anymore and that
that happened so I yes in recruiting
danwon at that time remember now as the
number one recruit the country they
don't mean an area just was that it was
you know it would have been very easy to
say hey I'll take that and I'll take
that and do this but my parents I wanted
to go to USC and that is the honest to
god truth and I said here today need and
I'm transparent about everything
at no time John Robinson's you'll love
this sitting in my living room John
Robinson was there Paul Hackett was
there it was early February before
February 8th signing day was one of
John's last home visits and coach
Robinson sat there at his national
championship ring on his finger he goes
Sean we want you you're the number one
recruit the country we'd love to have
you USC and this is I'm telling you
verbatim he said and we're gonna put you
in an environment to be successful he
said but if you don't come to USC we're
still gonna show up on Saturday and
we're still gonna win and he shook my
family fan I looked at my dad he left
with Paul Hackett about five minutes
after my dad said I think you want to be
a part of that don't you
and that I promise you as I said here
and then I made the decision six days
seven days later to go to USC over BYU
talking to Sean Salisbury Sports Talk
790 Houston the hosts their former NFL
quarterback and former ESPN NFL analyst
game more important to USC or Notre Dame
this weekend I think because of their
position now the way Notre Dame and the
way I've set up probably them but then
even if we were on five it's important
to us and it to me everybody will say
well USC UCLA that's the rivalry because
they're right across town not and that's
not true even though we played high
school ball against those guys the more
important game is USC Notre Dame this
game the the feeling you get the
national coverage it's SC Notre Dame
it's obviously better when one's number
one and no one's number four but I think
Notre Dame
we've got a lot to play or in clay
Helton I think Notre Dame's in probably
a better position even though the pac-12
so in the national scope of things but
I'll promise your recruiting wise this
is always marked on the calendar for SC
Ted told him with our coach after John
Roberts left we are sitting in South
Bend
the day before did snow I'm just trying
to paint a picture typical fall days
snowed in South Bend we were in the
locker in the day before teammate am i
Troy West and I was a very dear friend
got in a fight in a fistfight in the
locker room the day before the game
because the tensions were so high and
we're still best great buddies this day
well the next day comes around South
Bend little bit cold Ted told our comes
walking in he says we got a special
guest speaker today she said okay who
former players going to be in comes
coach METEC and you know everybody
revered se it's coach John Mackay and he
stood up they told us sniff and he said
at no time Roseville UCLA game played in
the NFL on Sundays you will never play
in a game did you remember more than
this one in South Bend and he was right
I can i UCLA game and some other games
but I could remember just play like a
champion walking down that tunnel where
we both come out of the same real close
to each other show the feeling of the
stadium being right on you looking
through touchdown Jesus and throwing and
the feeling I got my parents were in the
stands I'll never forget it coach McKay
was right to this day and to use to UFC
players this rivalry is the most
important one and they don't forget this
game or this moment no matter what
happens in their career before I let you
go the importance of this game coming up
this Sunday the Texans against the
Chiefs with deshaun Watson against
Patrick mahomes how important is it for
Watson and the Texans huge fan because
here in Houston it's a football state
and our - should I say Texas but in this
city it may be a football state for the
perception in this town it's an Astros
city right now and it has been for three
years and I think for it's not - Shawn
Watson people here tread lightly because
they still trust Bill O'Brien the
ability to go back to back to back type
of games
great game and go for the throat and
play not to lose I mean play to win as
opposed to not to lose and that'll be
important this week they're gonna have
to post third take the over in this game
both teams are going to score and I
think if you flip-flop Watson and stuck
in where my Holmes is and put the Holmes
where Watson is you'd say well Andy Reid
I think is a better offensive play
caller and more innovative and Watson
may even be further along and he's
already a cop six or seven guy in the
league but mahomes his arm strength and
everything he does he's so freaky and
everybody would take him first and I
would too but on the national scope for
the respect that the Texas one and just
for a division that the Colts aren't
going to go away and this is huge dish
on Watson's a different player dan is
DNA is through the roof like mahomes but
they have got to attack and I think
people here want Bill O'Brien to prove
that we're not going to go and try to
win 17 to 14 even though it'd be a win
so you know you got a score so be
aggressive like you were against Atlanta
and you're going to have to match my
homes throw to throw for Texans for me
they're going to have to just not give
up the big play make mahomes go five
series 80 yards 12 play drives instead
of giving him that window to hit the big
play you limit the big play and make my
holes patient they can stay in it
I still like Kansas City at home though
we were talking about this in the first
hour of the program and that's would you
rather have Odell Beckham or Julian
Edelman all for consistency Edelman
because especially in that offense Tom
lives by the shallow crosser he hits he
what he does he keeps hitting singles
damn and then you saw last night single
but let's say this Shawn you're the
starting quarterback and when it's not
Tom Brady and the GM comes to you and
says we can have Edelman or Odell
Beckham same price you pick you're the
quarterback the average guy of course
because Dan it's like the big thrower
you'll take the measurables a lot of
times before you'll take the six-four
guy before you take the six look at with
this you see the unbelievable skill set
and say well if he had a guy gets in the
ball every time Beckham would rub catch
2,000 yards worth of balls yes because
when all is equal who's tougher
to cover if you had of course it's
Beckham depending on the system and the
quarterback Braves can make me play
sloppy catch nine balls in the game now
let's take anything away from Edelman
but Edelman is a great player but and
more consistent because the quarterback
but Beckham more spectacular there's no
doubt I'd take him first
good stuff Sean have a great weekend and
always great to hear from you great to
hear from you and if I get another
cattle offer to me and it will split the
beef brother I'll talk to you
Thank You Sean for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]